I wanted to table this Elon Musk
situation with Twitter because I've been
loving the the [ __ ] uh that's funny
let me show you the uh the meme Harvest
is the best meme Harvest ever he's
having such a good time like he's doing
dude he's such a troll like this is like
this is an actual Elon Musk account like
this is him Chief twin yeah he doesn't
give a [ __ ] he put this out ligma and
Johnson had it coming and he's got like
okay
the Emojis after it and he's throwing
out of Twitter with their boxes of [ __ ]
and this is like after he got rid of
those three uh c-suite employees as CEO
I think the CFO and that [ __ ] smug
legal [ __ ] that was on The Joe Rogan
podcast with Tim Poole they're just like
no we're not censoring anybody yeah it's
always it's always foreigners too that
don't value American values or
traditions and these these people that
talk about oh globalism is a big thing
and they introduce these new ideas I am
so I am so glad when someone in the
group's like hey man I had something
happen at work oh I lost my job you feel
kind of bad from but people like this
Rich you know that they're smug and
they're so up their ass with themselves
that good riddance I'm really glad to
see it um okay you know the people that
have been fired by musk a lot of them
don't look very Alpha to me a lot of the
males and it kind of goes back to
remember Jordan Peterson said weak men
are the most dangerous men and you know
I just firmly believe that and I believe
there's a lot of weak men who are in a
lot of powerful positions in these
organizations and they're just like they
get to take out their power then because
they didn't have power in the schoolyard
they didn't have power in their social
group and there were nerds and they
became very successful and this is their
way of getting back at people is control
and speech and you know that's how they
exert their power yeah no straight up I
mean it's it's just you know it's that
whole Karma thing it's like the whole
Silicon Valley you know group of of tech
companies and especially social you know
social media like we used to have our
private group on Facebook
um years ago and it's like every week
somebody was getting like a Facebook fan
for like a day to three days to a week
there was a time you know somebody got
banned for a month to say one time I got
banned for a week for like some [ __ ]
very basic ass post I put in the uh uh
group I think it's just like okay this
is stupid this is not sustainable we got
to get off this platform it's [ __ ]
just ridiculous like you can't even like
it's a private group it's like you know
you're in your own house sort of talking
and nobody else can see it on the
platform sort of thing except for their
algorithms or if they want to look at
your conversations and it's like we
don't like what you guys are talking
about in there so we're gonna [ __ ]
lock you out for a week like yeah so
Karen calls the cops yeah yeah it's like
a [ __ ] algorithm that calls a cop
somebody like that's how [ __ ]
pathetic it is there's there's a hunter
Biden and meme going around at the
moment for the uh the Halloween costume
and it says that Ukrainian oil executive
yeah and if you post that on Facebook
you'll get banned uh one of my friends
sent it to me in Facebook private
messenger and they deleted it from a
private message and he sent it again
just to be sure because he taught us
nonsense and they deleted it from the
private message no I'm sure if that was
Donald Trump's tax returns he was
sending me that you know were stolen in
New York state they wouldn't have a
problem but again weak weak people with
power are dangerous hey guys I really
hope that you enjoy that short clip if
you did consider supporting the creation
of content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out